welcome to the heavy spoilers show i'm
your host paul aka
the bad [ __ ] who's about to break down
the first episode
of the new star wars clone wars spin-off
to celebrate may the fourth
be with you disney plus has just dropped
the first episode which will be seeing
its follow-up come friday
the 70-minute epic has a lot to unpack
from it and throughout this video we'll
be discussing all the ins and outs of
its plot
the easter eggs things you missed and
what might be happening next time
now i know a lot of you are jumping on
here as a starting point after missing
the clone wars
so if you need a catch-up i thought i'd
do a quick character breakdown on
everyone in this squad
as you can probably tell the bad batch
are clones of jango fett
but you might notice that they have
different features and characteristics
as opposed to the typical grunts because
django's dna strain was repeatedly used
over and over
it meant that it became somewhat diluted
and thus the kamino cloners experimented
on certain batches
in order to see if they could make
improvements to them the group itself is
made up of hunter
who is the leader of the team he's
pretty much the rambo of the bad batch
who's able to see electromagnetic
frequencies
next is rekka who is british and strong
and juxtaposing him is
tech who is a nerd
he's such a nerd there's also crosshair
who is an expert marksman
and lastly is echo now whilst echo looks
like one of sid's toys in toy story
that's because he's been through a lot
he gained the nickname echo because at
the training academy
he used to repeat every order upon being
given it
he worked alongside captain rex and ekko
was apparently killed during the battle
at the citadel
however we discovered in season seven of
the clone wars that he was actually kept
in stasis
and his mind was harvested by the
separatists through him they gained
strategies and formations in order to
help them in the war
and the bad batch in rex ultimately
ended up rescuing him
now the episode itself starts off with
the title screen for the clone wars
this is red hinting towards how the saga
ended with vader and palpatine carrying
out order 66
but the show itself actually picks up in
the midst of the final battle
of that saga now the card then burns
away to showcase the bad batch in
imperial grey
however there are touches of the rebel
burgundy in there to hint at what
direction we will be going with the
group
the episode is called aftermath and it
starts off with a propaganda reel
much in the same vein that all the clone
wars episodes did
i absolutely love these touches and i'll
let you know that this was a direct
continuation of what had come before
the last time we saw the bad batch they
were rescuing echo
but we joined them on kolar in an
assault being led by jedi master depa
billaba
if this is your first time jumping onto
the show then you might recognize the
character from the prequel trilogy
she actually served on the jedi council
when qui-gon announced that he believed
that anakin skywalker was the chosen one
and she has appeared throughout the saga
it's at this point where we introduced
to her padawan
caleb doom who has served at his side
for many years
he looks very similar to when we last
saw him and he's brought the bad batch
along for the fight
i'll be talking about what he goes on to
be later on but he's
a very important character in this show
and rebels
these guys need a big introduction and
they get one through rolling a bowler
down a hill
that takes out a large battalion of
battle droids so that they can swoop in
and do what they do best now they're
referred to as clone force 99
because they were the 99th batch of
troopers using jango fett's dna
as you can see if you're having dna
problems i feel bad for you son
i got 99 clone forces and the batch is
one hit me
now they use the weight of the armored
assault tanks against them
and much like how luke did with the
8080s they apply cables to their hull
in order to destroy them wrecker pushes
one over the edge
and this demonstrates just how strong he
is compared to a regular clone
after the battle the batch leave with
caleb but before we can celebrate the
win
order 66 is sent out throughout the
galaxy by palpatine
because the batch were given different
strains of dna the control chip
implanted in their brains
cannot fully override their free will
thus they don't carry the complete
mindless drone mentality
that means they follow orders without
question speaking of following orders
without question
it's at this point that you will carry
out the order to like comment subscribe
and by my merch now there are other
characters in the clone wars who too
resisted this order
including captain rex watch the last
four episodes of the clone wars season
seven if you want to see the arc play
out
as well as the socatanos and where we
last saw her before the mandalorian
in the woods the batch go looking for
caleb and crosshair believing orders are
orders
tries to kill him at several points
hunter takes a different approach though
and just as confused as caleb is he
tries to talk him around
instead he flees and the character would
actually go on to become kanan
a big player in the series rebels who
ended up training ezra bridget
hunter states that he stunned the
character and he died whilst jumping
over the waterfall
but crosshair suspects that this is a
lie and even scans the area to check
i believe that he saw footprints on the
other side of the ravine
and knows that caleb survived but let me
know if you disagree
they return to camino and are approached
by a pair of alpha 3 nimbus class
viewing star fighters
which are slightly different in design
to the v-wing airspeeder yeah
make sure you remember the difference
yeah wouldn't want you looking any
dumber than you already do
now the clones are just smurfing around
and with the war over
they're moving on to the next phase of
the imperial takeover
the hunters shock they've got shock
troopers on deck and the bodies of the
jedi are being silently snuck out
like when you try and get a one-night
stand past your parents
clearly the divide between them and the
regular grunts is starting to grow
although echo was originally part of
these because of the experimentation
that was carried out on him
he doesn't feel the need to give into
this pre-programming we can also see
that he's wearing an
aj cyborg construct similar to the
character lobot from the empire strikes
back
perhaps highlighting why he is able to
advance beyond the typical grunts
palpatine holds a school assembly and
this has echoes of several dictator
speeches from history
he announces the creation of the
galactic empire which
will pretty much enforce a police state
in the galaxy that all must answer to
the republic is now officially a
dictatorship in which there will be no
democracy
and palpatine will be able to rule
without question the jedi will be hunted
down and destroyed
but clearly this doesn't sit well with
the bad batch who now view their peers
as being mindless idiots who will
happily follow a lie
lots of political subtext in it and in
the next scene the character amiga
greets the bad batch
saying that she's a big fan she's a
curious medical assistant
and we know from the trailers that she's
gonna play a big role in the show
hunter states that the day keeps getting
weirder and weirder and it definitely
gets worse with the arrival of admiral
talking
when we last saw him in the saga he was
overseeing the construction of the death
star
and the character has of course appeared
in many things including a new hope in
rogue one
he's brought some bad news with him and
now that the war is over
the empire has decided to cease all
production to the clones
one of the big questions that always
hung over the prequel and
original trilogy was why did the empire
decide to stop using them
though this has been discussed several
times throughout the law
i'm glad that they added in an answer
here for people who might just have been
sticking to the main saga so far
we learn that the cost and the fact that
they can just enlist boys without giving
them any choice
means that they'll be able to quickly
create an empire and thus it's pointless
going through this process
just be careful though mate yeah they're
pretty crap shots
no wonder you had two death stars blow
up your cheapskate
now we see the bad batch in the mess
hall which is of course
very similar one that was showcased in
attack of the clones
they're joined by amiga and we quickly
see that the prejudice mind state
created by the empire
has slowly started to seep into the
other troops they're even viewing the
bad batch as the other
and calling them horrendous horrendous
terms
like the sad batch because they can now
operate without question
they will and i like that they showcased
a dark side to the clones
excuse the crap pun now they make a mess
in the mess hall
which is an even worse pun and talking
just so happens to be inspecting it at
this time
echo is knocked out and he wakes up to
find that he's being scanned by
az3459485793069
whilst amigo waits at his bedside
because of the experimentation that was
carried out on him
he gets ptsd and smacks the scanner away
before he's calmed down
he's anxious that tarkin has arrived and
the last time he saw him was during the
citadel mission
that led to his apparent death tarkin
wants to test them
and they run a combat simulator which is
very similar to the one in which we
first met ekko
season 3 episode 1 titled clone cadets
introduced echo
and his original squad initially they
were unable to complete the mission
because the team refused to work
together
but after some guidance from another
defective clone called 99
they managed to pull it off it's a
really good episode that sets up a lot
in this one
and as always it's like poetry they
rhyme now whereas in the episode the
troops faced a lot of trouble
the bad match easily complete the
mission and thus tarkin makes the
cloners switch to live rounds
to truly test how strong they are we see
what i believe
is an iteration or prototype for the
dark troopers
and if i'm right which i'm usually not
then you may recognize these as being
some of the more terrifying droids
in the mandalorian the bad batch have to
improvise in order to survive
and it's a great action scene that shows
they're pretty well equipped to handle
anything that the empire might throw at
them
talking clearly views them as being
superior soldiers
but is worried that they're disobedient
and we are left questioning crosshairs
loyalty
when we learn a report was filed stating
that caleb escaped
tarkin sends them to the under on sector
which contains a jungle planet of the
same name
during the clone wars count dooku caused
a lot of torment on this planet
and tarkin says there currently exists a
separatist force
which he wants talking out eh they go to
head out but amiga gives them a warning
that tarkin has been talking to the
kamino cloners
and that he doesn't trust clones i'm
sorry that was shockingly bad
omega scared of the change that she can
see happening
wants to go with them but hunter rejects
this notion
they travel to under on and covertly
scan the perimeter and discover that the
camp isn't full of the separatist
insurgents
as they first thought as tarkin said he
was questioning their loyalty
and whether they would blindly follow
orders so he set this trap which
involved killing innocent people
they're ambushed by the republic
fighters there who refuse to join the
empire
some of them are done in grey helmets
with a red symbol in the middle
and the coloration of this is very
similar to the logo of the bad batch
itself
here we meet saw guerrera who's looking
a lot better than we last saw him in
rogue one
a key cog in the formation of the rebels
it's nice to come across him in his
younger days
and see how he started the fight against
the imperials
so of course commanded several people
and through his depiction
we really get the idea of why they would
follow him
even the bad batch question what side
they're on and they decide to take arms
with him
though this doesn't sit well amongst
some of the members
i'm looking at you crosshair now the
term i was just following orders
is something that has been used
throughout history the nuremberg trials
which dealt justice to those complicit
in the holocaust
saw the phrase being put across several
times by the guilty
in that atrocious time over 10 million
innocent jews
poles and people of other demographics
were systemically exterminated by the
german forces
and those that carried it out clearly
thought that what they were doing was
just
crosshair utters the phrase at one point
to say why it's fine to murder innocent
people
and it's a great line that hints towards
the darker side of human history
now it turns out a probe droid was
following them the entire time
and it has been reporting the status of
their mission before crosshair can take
leadership
hunter shoots it and recalls that amiga
warned them
not to return to kamino it's at this
point that we also get to confirm that
amiga is actually a clone
and also yeah they call her omega and
also pronounce it amiga in this episode
so i don't want to hear nothing in the
comments yet about how i'm saying it
wrong
i block you a pro i'll bloody block you
now there's a lot of mystery around who
she actually is
and theories that she might be a clone
of the duchess
which is obi-wan's attempt at a child
it's also possible that she is a
force-sensitive clone
and her hairstyle is similar to
palpatine's in the phantom menace
so maybe the caminos were attempting to
replicate people who possessed the force
hence her importance now i'm not 100 and
just off the accent
she might simply be a gender swap of
fete let me know below whatever your
theories are
and the group mount a rescue mission to
break her out of dodge
they return home for the third act of
the episode and here the plan is simple
break in find amiga click subscribe
meet back at the ship and hi taylor out
of there things aren't that easy though
and the bad batch end up being
confronted by their own brothers and
talking
who accuse them of treason the plan
wasn't a complete failure though and
they're reunited with amiga in jail
i also love how their armor is stripped
away and we can see the black clothing
under the trooper uniform
i can sometimes be spotted through the
slits crosshair is still furious that
they've been
jailed and clearly he is wrestling with
his programming
he's called to be scanned and we see
that his neural implant is still
active which is making it so that he's
more prone to the brainwashing carried
out by it
amiga is able to climb through the hole
in the cell and she unlocks the door
they manage to get their weapons and
start the rescue mission for crosshair
who we see now completely indoctrinated
and leading a clone unit
he is wearing a black imperial uniform
and we watch as he
hunter and the clones go head to head in
a classic star wars shootout
wrecker uses metal paneling his cover
similar to what he did in the clone wars
season 7
and the caminos helped a bad batch to
keep the door open so they can escape
amiga stuns crosshair and the group
managed to flee
likely to be pursued by him as the rest
of the season goes on
now i actually got given early access to
the first episode
but i gave disney the wrong email
address for the screening portal
so i didn't actually have an account to
watch them on feel like a bit of a clown
or clone hey but i do think that this is
the way that the series gonna continue
i imagine that they'll manage to disable
a chip within crosshairs brain
but it's going to be interesting to see
how it all plays out
we end with the group heading out for
the first time without a mission
and amiga goes into space for the first
time too
they want to lay low but now their
crosshair is behind them
and thus decide to go to j19 now they're
likely going to be meeting the character
laquain
who ended up settling on the planet and
marrying a tweelek
le quaine was a clone trooper but he
deserted the army in order to have a
life on his own
and he's pretty much an outcast so yeah
the bad batch are gonna fit in with him
i can see this definitely being the next
person that they come across
but if you disagree let me know in the
comments
now as for my thoughts on the episode as
a whole have to say yeah
really enjoyed it it was a very sad day
when the clone wars ended as it's one of
the best star wars animated shows out
there
scratch that the best star wars animated
show out there
so seeing it come to an end it was very
bittersweet
however i'm glad that disney have done a
spin-off and are going with the bad
batch
and telling their journey in the
expanded lore it's a very fun opening i
love the dialogue between the group
and you really get the camaraderie that
these soldiers have it's basically the
star wars version of band of brothers
and they are a band of brothers that are
sort of a band
of brothers because because they're
clones and it's great seeing them out on
the battlefield
fighting it out with the forces of evil
i love how this is also telling
offshoots of the star wars story
and it's going to be great to see more
things focused around grand moff talking
and of course the stormtroopers now
obviously i'd love to hear your thoughts
on the show so make sure you comment
below and let me know
as a thank you for interacting with the
video you'll be entered into a prize
draw on the 30th of may
in which we're giving away three copies
of the godzilla vs kong collection
all you have to do to be on the chance
of winning is like the video make sure
you subscribe with notifications on and
drop a comment below with your thoughts
on the first entry
the winners of last month's competition
are on screen right now so if that's you
then message me on twitter at
heavyspoilers if you want something else
to watch then make sure you check out
our breakdown of the eternals trailer
which will be linked on screen right now
we've gone over some of the cool easter
eggs in it
what you need to know about the
characters and it's basically the best
video i've ever made in the space of
five minutes because it was a tight one
now without the way thank you for
sitting through the video i've been poor
i'll see you on friday yeah see you on
friday make sure you come back
take care and have a good week until
then peace